i get a video explaining how to play the  game yes yes you can the way it works is  you have one or two people that are like  it if you're not it you start on the  third floor which is here and your goal  is to make it down the stairs around the  corner and to the basement  into a room without getting tapped so  like we picked this one and if you're it  then your goal is to tag everyone before  they can get to the basement that's why  you need multiple staircases because  otherwise you're just guarding like one  door and you can't really play if you  get tagged you're frozen you can't move  you can be unfrozen by someone that  hasn't been tagged and if you're in the  room you're safe but you can leave to go  untag someone but then you can also be  tagged